¿Qué vamos a hacer en este video? Vamos a pensar
en fracciones equivalentes. Digamos que tenemos la
fracción 3/4 y quiero pensar ¿cuál es el número
equivalente en octavos?, ¿a cuántos octavos es
igual 3/4? Y para representar estos octavos
podría poner un signo de interrogación aquí,
pero en su lugar sólo pondré una letra
y. ¿Cuánto debería ser y? 3/4 = y/8,
y ¿cuánto tiene que ser y para que
esto sea verdad? Y antes de decirte
que pauses el video y que intentes trabajar
por tu cuenta -lo que haré en un momento-,
te daré una pequeña pista. Tratemos de representar
3/4, lo representaré con este rectángulo, así que
lo dividiré en cuatro secciones iguales, veamos,
esto sería dividirlo aproximadamente a la mitad,
lo estoy dibujando a mano así que no es perfecto,
pero estas deberían ser secciones iguales,
las áreas de cada una de estas secciones deben ser
iguales. Ahí tienes, esta es mi versión dibujada
a mano. De modo que tres de esos cuartos -y lo
haré en morado-, tres de esos cuartos, uno, dos
y luego sólo por diversión haré este de aquí,
aquí tenemos 3/4. Ahora, queremos pensar en esto
en términos de octavos. Voy a dibujar otro entero,
pero esta vez en lugar de dividirlo en cuartos lo
voy a dividir en octavos. Primero hagamos los
cuartos, sólo porque es fácil mirar lo que está
arriba, estos son cuartos, y luego dividiré cada
uno de los cuartos en dos, eso me da octavos,
muy bien ya casi está. El dibujo es en realidad la
parte más difícil. Cada uno de estos es un octavo,
está dibujado a mano. Imaginemos, si hubiera
ocho secciones iguales ¿cuántos octavos son
equivalentes a 3/4? Pausa el video e intenta
resolverlo por tu cuenta. Muy bien. Bueno,
podemos resolver esto visualmente, podríamos
decir que este primer cuarto es equivalente a
este octavo y este octavo, de modo que este
primer cuarto es igual a 2/8, este segundo
cuarto es igual a otros 2/8, y este tercer cuarto
es igual a otros 2/8, así que ¿cuántos octavos
he sombreado? Bueno, tengo uno, dos, tres,
cuatro, cinco, seis octavos, tengo 6/8, 3/4
es equivalente a 6/8. En este escenario y
= 6, entonces podemos decir que 3/4 = 6/8.
Ahora hagamos otro ejemplo. Lo que podemos ver en
este círculo superior es que lo hemos dividido en
6 secciones iguales, cada una de éstas es una de
las 6 secciones iguales o 1/6, y podemos ver que
una, dos, tres, cuatro de ellas están sombreadas,
así que lo que hemos representado en este círculo
superior es 4/6. Lo que quiero pensar es ¿cuántos
tercios equivalen a 4/6? Pausa este video y
piénsalo. Una vez más: ¿cuántos tercios equivalen
a 4/6? En lugar de simplemente poner un signo de
interrogación pondré la letra x, ¿cuánto debería
ser x para que estas dos cosas sean equivalentes?
U otra forma de pensar en esto es 4/6 = x/
3, 4/6 es igual a ¿cuántos tercios? Muy bien,
hagamos esto juntos. Una forma de pensar en esto
es, veamos: para 1/3, para que podamos hacer esto
igual a 1/3, parece que eso es equivalente a lo
que estoy marcando en anaranjado aquí arriba,
eso también tiene sentido. Si tuviera que dividir
1/3 en dos esto sería 1/6 y esto sería 1/6,
necesitas 2/6 para completar 1/3 o cada tercio
es equivalente a 2/6, de modo que esto es 1/3
justo aquí, y esto es equivalente a dos de
estos sextos. Pero aún no hemos terminado,
tenemos otros 2/6, podríamos decir que estos
2/6 son equivalentes a otro tercio, es un poco
complicado porque no pusieron este sexto al lado
de este sexto, pero si tuviéramos que moverlo,
digamos que debemos mover este sexto, así que voy
a colorear este en blanco y voy a sombrear este en
su lugar. Puedes ver que estos 2/6 que tenemos
aquí, estos 2/6, son equivalentes a este tercio
que tenemos aquí. Entonces, lo que puedes
ver es que nuestros 4/6 que hemos sombreado
son equivalentes a 2/3, otra forma de decirlo
es que x = 2, x = 2, 4/6 = x/3 o 4/6 = 2/3.